all right guys
bang bang i have fred here with me
they have an incredible story as to how
they got the bitcoin fund approved
on the canadian exchanges but we're
going to get to that in a minute thank
you so much for doing this sir
hey nice to be here absolutely let's
jump right into your background
um tell us a little bit about yourself
where did you grow up and what did you
do before you fell
down the bitcoin and crypto rabbit hole
wow you know first of all i think i'm
i'm running right up there with some of
the older guys in crypto
so uh uh so i've done a lot but uh
you know i i definitely got the you know
shall we say the
uh entrepreneurial bug and it all came
from a guy by the name of uh howard
kelly
uh my best friend was peter kelly he was
an artist
and my mom was an artist and they do the
two of them got along really really well
and peter's father was president of
company at the time called guardian
trust company
which was a big gold trader in the late
70s and
80s and had been around forever and
i was in economics and business and gold
trading and foreign forex trading
so by the time i was 23 he made me a
manager of the international forex and
precious metal trading operations of
this company called guardian trust so
here i am 23 green and whatever he
wanted
i got to do and howard was always
thinking of the next thing and he said
well let's set up a discount brokerage
firm let's
uh do this or do that and then at one
point in time he goes fred why don't we
list gold silver and platinum
certificates
on the montreal stock exchange because
investment advisors
don't have any way to buy gold for their
client they're not going to stand out
the line on the street with a million
dollars in cash and
get a gold bar and then walk out you
know and that's what it was like
in the heydays of the 70s and 80s with
inflation going through the roof
so uh i said sure let's do this and so i
uh we applied to list gold silver and
platinum on the montreal stock exchange
to the much quebec securities commission
at the time
and their first response was hang on a
second it's volatile
it's non-traditional custodians and it's
used for criminal purposes
why would we ever list this on the
montreal stock exchange
so fast forward 40 years later here i am
going
i want to list bitcoin on the toronto
stock exchange they go hang on a second
it's volatile speculative and used for
criminal purposes like
what's up with that anyways by 1986 i
think tom sent you a picture of me on
the montreal gazette as a 26 year old
little rookie
uh you know with a newspaper saying we
finally got gold silver and platinum
certificates listed on the montreal
stock exchange
which was really the beginning of
investment advisors using gold as a
you know an asset diversifier and that's
really where we went
um following that my real claim to fame
was i was joined
a group of amazing guys fidelity
investments had come to canada and after
spending three years and
millions tens of millions of dollars
they were about to close the operation
it was after the 87 crash they said
we're dead here we're going to close it
and a great guy by name of john
simpson had heard me and a guy named joe
canada and we took the company from 80
million to seven and a half
billion in the next four years so by the
time i was like
31 years old we were running this
amazing organization for
easily one of the best financial
institutions in the world uh
fidelity and it's fun to see abigail
johnson running fidelity right now and
you know you know i remember slow
dancing with her at the christmas party
in the
late 80s and early 90s and she is
absolutely an amazing brilliant
wonderful woman
so i have all the numbness respect for
her
and uh so then we went from fidelity
and then now this is what i'm going to
blow your mind
i left fidelity i did a uh
i went to do a re-engineering of a
brokerage firm
to try and get people to invest in what
was called the information super highway
because the information super highway
had just been invented and i would take
out
i'd rent out imax theaters i'd stand on
stage
uh in this imax theater and we would
take a dial up phone and put it on a uh
uh you know on a a modem
ding ding ding ding ding ding and on the
imax theory all of a sudden the
internet would pop up on the big screen
and it was originally the inter
in you know uh information super highway
and then the world wide web
and i think there were maybe 10 websites
in canada let me search the 10
websites and show what people what
surfing was about i come out on stage
with a hawaiian shirt and sunglasses to
surfing
usa so uh we did that
uh and then i left there because i
thought i had come up with the best
investment idea in the history of the
world
and the reason was is i had gone through
a divorce and i had a
beautiful daughter who had like eight
sets of grandparents now that i've been
remarried
and i had my new son and the problem was
is for
you know holidays and birthdays and
everything she'd get a hundred dollars
or two hundred dollars to three hundred
dollars
and i said i said geez imagine if there
was one company in the world
that whenever a child is born that
parents would send a hundred dollars to
that account at that company
but anywhere in the world and it wasn't
going to be a financial institution
so i came up with the idea for this
thing called the disney fund
i actually wrote a business plan that
was called
imagine which is a children's story book
about children being born and
every and uncle and grandparent would do
this
so i sent these business plans to the
entire board of directors of disney
and their strategic planning committee i
got half of them back saying we don't
disney doesn't entertain non-solicited
business opportunities
so yeah well fine so i decided i
could try and get a meeting with michael
eisner and everybody who says they know
him can get him
you know can't do it so i called michael
eisner every morning
for about three months and got to speak
to got to know all his assistants and
secretaries and everybody
which now is politically incorrect but
uh finally the vp of finance said
freddie i love the idea
he says fly to l.a we're doing a
strategic planning meeting next week
we're going to get you to
come in and present to us and i'm just
going
mind-blown this is facebook before
facebook like every family
every child in the world hooking up
together on the internet
anyways uh my wife and myself and my
three-month-old son flew to l.a
sat in a daze inn next to the parking
lot and
nothing after three days so we went to
kinko's printed up more business
plans put them in every mercedes benz or
better in the parking lot
anyways finally got the call and said uh
yeah it's not going to happen so i ran a
nice jaguar convertible and drove with
my wife and my kid up to napa valley
so here we are in napa valley enjoying a
little bit of a vacation
and i'm reading old disney um
annual reports and i find out that
michael eisner has a cottage
about two mountain ranges from me in
vermont so i had a home in vermont and
40 acres and eisner was just
around the corner so that summer i sent
a couple of business plans
to michael eisner's house and that's
when they threatened me with uh
restraining orders
so i'm your only good i'm your only
guest that has almost got a restraining
order from michael eisner
for an investment idea that is amazing
and so take us from there to at what
point do you discover
bitcoin so um
i was running a multi-asset momentum
portfolio invented by jean mclandry and
max lemieux who were partners of mine
and
and i was down at the etf conference in
florida in
2014-15 and i met up with chris berniski
who i'm sure you know very well and and
uh kathy wood from arc
and i'm telling they had just launched
art and i've just want
i'm running this multi-asset momentum
and going
geez you know like every other hedge
fund manager we're looking for that
perfect non-correlated asset class
and chris goes well i've got to tell you
about bitcoin so i've heard about it
i've read about it
um he says well yeah he says i said but
there's no way
to buy it in a public fund he said okay
he says well let's
put on a quest and i said you know what
i could probably get this done in canada
because i did it for gold
40 years earlier so i did the standard
thing
i maxed out my credit card every month
filed a lot of bitcoin in 2014-15
and if you read her uh original
prospectus
it's very similar to chris's book crypto
assets
uh he him and jack tater wrote a great
book called crystal
crypto assets bitcoin and beyond
and a lot of that was the base of the
original bitcoin prospectus
so uh but my real life bitcoin stories
my son had gotten a scholarship and went
off to andover
outside of boston a prep school and uh
his allowance was 200 u.s a month so the
first month i sent him 200 u.s and i got
a phone call and i go what's up he goes
says dad i thought my allowance was 200
i said yeah he says well i only got 160.
i look at it i said oh yeah cibc took 25
bucks and bank of america took 15.
so you only get 160. he goes no dad
that's not how it works and he goes
he goes yes son that's exactly how it
works
so he says well what are we going to do
about this and i said well what we'll do
is
open up a an account at coinbase and i'm
going to send you
one bitcoin which was 200 at the time so
i send him one bitcoin the next month
and goes bing and he goes
wow that was fast that's cool he kept
the bitcoin so next month i sent him 0.9
bitcoins and he goes
dad you were supposed to send me one
bitcoin i said no bitcoin went up
so so i only send you 0.9 which is the
200
he goes no dad that's not how it works i
go yes son that's exactly how it works
so he comes back from school a year
later he's got all this bitcoin in this
wallet and i'm going what are you living
off of he says all that fiat currency in
my bank accounts that are devaluing as
we speak
and i go there's my boy so
it's our you know that's how we really
got in into bitcoin
um so then we went on the quest to
launch the first bitcoin fund in the
world on a major exchange
and really uh uh we looked at a bunch of
different things a lot of people were
doing reverse takeovers and mining
companies
reverse takeovers of these you know
different types of funds and we just
said
you know what let's visit with the osc
and say we want to go on the front door
so we had a the head of the investment
funds branch
in ontario securities commission was a
guy by the name of john mountain
we had known for years bright visionary
kind of really cool guy
he goes we said do you want to be the
first regulator to approve a bitcoin
fund
enlisted on a major exchange in the
world it goes absolutely let's go
so uh we we follow preliminary
prospectus chris berniske
and duck and everybody wrote it we filed
it
uh we went through two different
editions and it was about to get
approved
then the regulators create this thing
called the launch pad to help digital
asset companies
you know make it through the regulatory
burden
faster well it did the exact opposite it
made us
stop the approval of the uh of the
bitcoin fund
and we said well how come they say well
we want
we don't know if bitcoin's a currency a
security or a commodity
i said well that's pretty irrelevant
because i'm licensed to manage
currencies securities and commodities i
don't care what you call it
you know we have legally constituted
this fund
they said well you have but we're
regulating you and we want to put terms
and conditions
to make you as a portfolio manager have
the expertise and right to
manage a digital asset fund so that took
them about a year
and this was 2017. so bitcoin went from
dollars you know or twelve hundred
dollars to
twenty thousand and then collapse and in
january they go now you're digital asset
managers and we're going whoopee
you like i mean we just missed the
biggest bull market on anything ever
right for a while so anyways we um
we refiled the prospectus and said we're
going to go again
and we were about to get approved kind
of we believe
you know in in mid 2018
and all of a sudden john mountain who's
about to sign off and approve it he gets
a
radical prostate cancer sorry radical um
uh cancer uh
and and he dies within like three months
of
of us being a per three weeks within
us being approved which with pancreatic
cancer sorry
and that was absolutely horrible it was
uh
and i had just come off a prostate
cancer
uh scare and had a radical prosthetic
and so remember your movembers and
get your psa check um
so so john passed away the new group
came
in they just said yeah we don't get this
bitcoin thing there's no way we're going
to accept it
so what happens is when a regulator
rejects a perspective what they have to
do is they actually have to articulate
the reasons
why they were rejecting it and in canada
they said
look here's it took them six months and
they said we're rejecting it because
we have questions about custody about
auditability about pricing about market
manipulation
and finally they always have this magic
card called it's not in the public
interest to launch a bitcoin fund
well in canada most of you know that we
had a couple of disasters with quadriga
cx
an exchange where the guy died in india
and to
you know he took what was it 240 million
of a hundred and ten thousand canadians
and it's not in the public interest to
have a regulated fund
like it made no sense at all um
but when so when they reject it we
looked at their reasons for rejection
and we said we can win this and we filed
uh basically a petition to go to a
public hearing in front of a judge
or commissioner to win the right to
launch the first bitcoin fund in the
world
and uh in october so we did that in the
summer of 2019
in october uh on halloween day we got
the
the results that said we had won on all
accounts and we have the right to launch
the first bitcoin fund in the world
which was amazing we're now like four
and a half years and five and a half
million dollars
into this and uh the judge's landmark
decision
was not a simple decision it was a very
complex decision it said
the application that we filed engages
the
foundational concepts of securities
legislation in canada
meaning a regulator it's not their job
to immunize people against volatility
risk
taking or technology or anything along
those lines
their job is to make sure that it is
legally constituted and safe and secure
in the eyes of the law and we went on
on on all accounts um
the the biggest one was custody and this
is when
the early custody companies were coming
out and they just done with they've gone
with the bit license now and
so we ended up there were really three
people you know where i'd hold 100
million or a billion dollars of bitcoin
right now
it's either coinbase fidelity or bitco
or you know but we selected gemini
um and uh there's another one of the
greatest books ever written bitcoin
billionaire
uh billionaires i think it's an amazing
story it was
you read that in one sitting so anybody
who hasn't read one you know
you've got to read that so we teamed up
with gemini
and um uh
and they had where it became stock 2
type 2 compliant
everything proper financial institution
that worked so we dealt with custody
then there was auditability so grant
thornton worldwide
in montreal has a group called cadillac
c
the last five years of francis pulio
worked there at one point in time and
jonathan
and everybody else and they created
something called cadillac c which was
designed to audit blockchain
transactions
specifically bitcoin transaction and
bitcoin wallets
so when we went to the we already were
running a multi-crypto asset fund
and it had already been audited by grant
thornton
and they said yeah they stood up in
front of the osce says you can't get an
audit
and grant thornton's sitting there
saying well we've audited one and we
think we can audit it so
you know you know who's the authority
here is it grant thornton is the osc
so we went on auditability pricing was a
little more complicated because you
couldn't use a single
index or a single benchmark or a single
exchange
so um one of our partners van neck owns
ten percent of three iq
uh plus or minus and in
van eck owns a company called enves so
gabor gerbax and the group at
venice created with us with sean comby
our cio created the uh envis
institutional bitcoin index so
we ended up selecting the indexes and
washing it of
all the noise that shows up in a bitcoin
index
and we believe it's the cleanest bitcoin
index uh around
so uh we proved to them that yes you
could price it properly and it wasn't
subject to manipulation market
manipulation was really kind of funny
and i'll just tell you this one story
there was over 10 000 pages of uh
testimony and the guy for the osc says
well you know there's market
manipulation
on an exchange in china and he goes yeah
fine
that exchange isn't in our index so but
he says here you're quoting mr bit from
xt
he says do you know mr bit for next t
the guy goes
no he says do you think that's his real
name
no he says well did you verify his data
did you
you scrub down into it like i mean
you're the ontario securities commission
you have access to all the data in the
world
and he goes he says okay he says no i
didn't do that he goes okay well your
next one is betty b
what's betty b's last name what does
betty b know
about market manipulation so he our
lawyer proceeded to
on the stand the whole crowd is sitting
there just going they're listening to
this and going
you know holy smokes so market
manipulation
really had nothing to do with us we're
all very familiar with the bart simpson
uh chart patterns that you get out of
china where it goes straight up and it
goes across i
come straight down or the reverse parts
upside down bart simpson
just goes down and coming back up none
of that
and ever ends up in the midst of a
publicly traded company that's priced at
4 p.m every every single day
and then again the final one was not in
the public interest the ontario
securities commission
always has the right to say it's not in
the public interest so if we're trying
to run
a uranium you know enriched uranium fund
coal storage in north north korea they
may say it's not in the public interest
to do so
so um the judge
literally said even though
that not in the public interest carries
an awful lot of weight an awful lot of
opportunity
it's not endless and he says it's not uh
it can't be used all the time or any
time
so we ended up winning on
all accounts and uh the problem is so we
went on october 31st
in ontario canada has 12 jurisdictions
so now we had to get approved in 12
other jurisdictions
and then we had to syndicate we did the
12 other jurisdictions we got syndicated
with none of the big canadian banks
which is a disappointment
they'll come on which tells me we're
early right we're early if
goldman sachs morgan stanley jp when
nobody's embracing it we're early
because when they embrace it we're
already there you you get that you under
understand that so we're still early
and so we're about to syndicate the
beginning of march we go what could
possibly go wrong
well apparently there's a global
pandemic that we haven't
checked the box off you know we had a
pre-market book of 100 million dollars
it went to zero because every investment
advisor in this country was more
concerned with
protection of wealth of their clients
and they were not looking for a new
asset
class um we were already running a
bitcoin fund of 15 million we rolled out
15 million in
went public at 15 million came out did
another
offering right after just before the
having did 50 million us then did
another 15 million us
we're doing about two one to two million
dollars a day of private placements
right now
and in the next few weeks the bitcoin
fund in canada qbtc.u will be a virtual
etf we'll be able to do what are called
at the market offerings
so you can subscribe to the fund every
single day
4 pm get units of the fund and you can
redeem them once a month so it's
virtually an etf with monthly
redemptions and daily subscriptions so
you know we're pretty excited about what
we're doing in canada with that
so talk to me about right now the types
of people so you mentioned kind of the
capital that you guys have gotten into
the fund
where is that coming from is that coming
from uh individuals
is that coming from kind of wealth
managers does that come from family
offices
institutions where are you seeing the
demand from
yeah so funny enough
it's tiny right it's a hundred million
dollars or
you know 100 million dollars in three
months we have maybe a handful of family
offices in canada which you know who all
the bitcoin interested family offices
are
and we do have and and this is really
the the real
crux of it pump is we have a regulated
manager running a regulated fund on a
major regulated exchange
so now every mutual fund in the world
should be coming to canada and buying
uh buying into you know a part of our
bitcoin fund to have that one percent in
their global tech fund
so there are three really you can
probably guess
who they are in canada tech funds that
or global go anywhere asset management
funds that
understand bitcoin they get it and these
are mutual funds that all show up as top
performing i mean all you have to do is
look at arc
and the performance of arc web because
they bought bitcoin you know
four years ago gbtc four years ago and
you know
they're one of the best performing etfs
in the united states so
we have a lot of canadian mutual funds
that are looking at putting our bitcoin
fund
into their funds and we hope that that
spreads to the us
and the rest of the world got it and
then you guys also have
uh an ether fund that is uh coming down
the pipe talk a little bit about that
yeah um first of all we have filed a
preliminary prospectus for the ether
fund
so therefore when you're in uh
prospectus offering you're not allowed
to
promote or or talk about it so the best
i can say
is you know um you know
it is filed it is public record that has
been filed
we're in the question period of it we
hope that this closes in the next month
or so
and any details of that fund can be you
know you can
get the preliminary prospectus from your
investment advisor and that's pretty
much all i'm allowed to say about that
that's fair uh talk a little bit about
the bitcoin fund and kind of where you
see this
going right do we see an etf coming down
the pipeline does this eventually
uh have a pathway to become the etf uh
or do you think that the bitcoin fund
uh will kind of serve as that exposure
uh for
uh for a good number of people for uh
for the persistent future
yeah so first of all um
the answer is you know etfs will come in
and and prevail and yes we could convert
this into an
etf but we're a virtual etf today
anyways right
you know you can subscribe at the end of
the day you know at nav
plus a little bit or at the market
offerings they're called atm offerings
not a lot of people understand what an
atm offering is at the market offering
but tesla just did a 5 billion dollar
atm mark uh offering
in the united states so everybody went
oh hang on what's this
so the laws in canada changed on august
31st
normally an atm offering you couldn't
offer more than 10
of your your capitalization and you
couldn't offer it more than four or five
times a year or whatever the number was
now you can offer it daily and you can
offer it to the maximum
so it's the new type of of what we call
an etf
so it's virtually an etf people will
learn what it is it's kind of like and
canada was the inventor by the way of
etfs
my chairman howard atkinson literally
wrote the book on etfs he was uh
he was at uh well before horizons in
blackrock and everybody else so
uh you know howard has literally written
version one two and three of what is an
etf
um so we're a virtual etf right now and
people will have to
figure that out and understand it having
said that
my vision is very different because of
the judge's ruling that we have
and that we're regulated and canada's a
very
safe and in understood jurisdiction
we'll be listed we believe in gibraltar
offshore jurisdiction in the next three
days or five days
if they come back to us quickly um we're
looking
we've been approached by people um
to listen europe and places such as
austria um
we've got a letter of intent to launch
in dubai
um we're obviously looking at singapore
so we're looking at the friendly
jurisdictions
but then we passport to london
hong kong and the new york stock
exchange
or nasdaq so we have every intention
there are a lot of restrictions we can't
go into the us
until we are a certain size of a certain
track record
and everything else but we'll have the
size we'll have the track record we'll
have everything else
so yeah i wouldn't be surprised to see
through iq applying for
an nyse listing or uh
another listing at some point in time
and just think of it you know some of
the biggest
close down funds on the new york stock
exchange there's sprout physical gold
spot physical silver
that are you know seven eight billion
dollar funds you know on the new york
stock exchange so
canada we have access to be able to do
those kind of listings so
we're always up for a good fight so you
know that
i love it talk a little bit uh about
bitcoin just in general right so outside
of the fund kind of how do you see the
asset today
and kind of where do you think we're
going over the next 18 24 months
yeah so when i was a floor trader in
montreal i remember seeing the price of
something going up and
when the old-time traders said more
buyers than sellers
so as long as bitcoin has more buyers
and sellers
and you know i'm a i'm an
honors degree student in economics and
an mba and if supplies like this
and demands like this the price is the
only outlet right
and you know with all respect to you
know warren buffett one of my
long time heroes the bitcoin boxing is
the most powerful secured computer
network in the world
and i have no idea how he thinks it's
worth zero
if warren buffett owned email or live
streaming
or you know or voice over internet
protocol warren buff would be even
richer than he is today
so why he doesn't own bitcoin i don't
know because you can actually own part
of the most secure powerful computer
network in the world
and i think a lot of people miss out on
the simplicity of the beauty of the
technology of what we have here
so you buy bitcoin for one of three
reasons because it's the most powerful
secure computer network in the world and
you want to own it
which i do or you think it's a store of
wealth
now the store of wealth a lot of people
have a lot of funny questions about the
store evolve
and when i wrote that article and got
gold silver and platinum listed on
montreal stock exchange
i mentioned in that article that i
thought that platinum would overtake
gold as the
store of wealth over gold because it was
more scarce
it was more geographically diversified
you could
mine it in more places and had greater
industrial uses
so i said platinum should be a better
store wealth than gold
what i forgot was there was already five
trillion dollars of gold embedded in
central banks
and there's no way you could ever amass
five trillion dollars worth of
platinum by the time we've got
five trillion dollars of bitcoin in
central banks of the world
and somebody says well i believe in
blockchain but i don't like bitcoin i'm
going
you have no idea what you're talking
about and when you talk about store of
wealth
i have four thousand dollar t-shirts and
two thousand dollar tubes i bought
dinner for people in venice
for 10 bitcoin well no i wouldn't do
that anymore i won't spend
any bitcoin so when people tell me you
know if you can't
bitcoin will never get a bid till you
can buy something with it and i said
that's why i wrote a white paper with
custom frank
and it's on medium about for bitcoin to
really
hit hyper grove 4 trillion dollars a day
of forex fiat is traded
every day until you get those traders
taking their phone and going i'm trading
us dollars for canadian dollars
instantaneous settlement bing bang zoom
for japanese yen for you know euros for
british pounds until they start doing
that and going holy crap i don't want to
own any of these fiat currencies
and now you're selling your us dollars
and buying bitcoin or you're selling
your canadian dollars and buying bitcoin
or you're yen and buying bitcoin until
we
can as a whole group get forex traders
to understand that stable coins will be
used as a means of currency
but stable coins are either going to be
on the bitcoin blockchain through liquid
or they're going to be
on you know or regular uh you know or
they're going to be
on you know ether or any one of the
others
other blockchains so until the world
starts
trading digital currencies we own a
company called
have a company with uh mavennet systems
out of canada
called canada stable corp and i'm going
to pitch that to your private equity
company
at some point in time because i love the
new fund that you just created
um but coming to stable corp you know we
sat down with a bank
famous bank and a famous asset manager
and we did
a four million dollar bond trade that
settled in t plus
three t plus three seconds at a cost of
two tenths of a cent
so if anybody who denies that all
securities trading all bond trading and
everything is going blockchain based and
bitcoin is
not the us dollar standard of the
blockchain well
they're just not getting it yet right so
and i'm preaching to the converted so
well they just haven't paid they haven't
paid attention right they haven't done
the work they haven't spent the time to
actually understand
how much more superior this is i think
right yeah and
and again getting involved in stable
points it's going to take
you know what are we we're here uh you
know 12 a bit in bitcoin
email was invented into in 1982. most
people didn't get their first email to
in canada until blackberry went from
being a little pager system into an
email system in 1994 really
so it took 12 years for people to adopt
email for them to adopt digital
currencies and everything else is going
to maybe take another
you know another while so we are so
early in this growth pattern and same
with voice over internet protocol
when that was invented you know we
didn't start using zoom and
and skype and everything for another 14
15 years
now we're 20 years so people's time
horizons are way too short
that's why i say you know when bitcoin
goes from a thousand to 20 000 in
2017 yep it was easily the biggest short
i've ever seen in my entire life
for people to be buying into the futures
i could see all those futures traders
going
this is going to be the biggest short or
easiest short
apart from you know mortgages and
during the mortgage crisis you know in
2008
so it was easily the big short for me
as far as i was concerned not because i
didn't like it
but bitcoin's price has followed its
growth pattern its adoption rate
you know there's no brain surgery here
stock to flow
anything safety you know uh safety dean
talks about
all of this the more power it gets the
more people want it the more people want
it the more powerful it gets the more
secure it gets and
goes round and round these are all
brilliant people and these hedge fund
guys
you know uh are amazing i was really um
uh i watched your podcast the guy from
microstrategy
and how he ended up with his his
investment in it
you know yeah there's a bit of a rolling
of the dice there but
the reality is you know it's not going
away
right it is probably more right than
wrong
right michael saylor from microstrategy
who put 85 percent of his balance sheet
500 million dollars put 425 million
bucks of it into
into bitcoin so yeah but one of my early
shareholders a guy named greg
foss who wants to talk about fiat and
and currencies you know the guy is
brilliant he knows everything about
trading about money about
governments about bond trading he knows
all the weaknesses and you should follow
him accurate boss
um he's he's absolutely amazing and
point on um but again he's
a maximal listen you have to adopt his
enthusiasm
i'm enthusiastic but i'm looking at the
entire
infrastructure together um
but when people say it's blockchain i
like not bitcoin that's when i shake my
head i'm going
you haven't even you haven't even
started to understand it yet
and that's that's right that's the
signal that they're starting yeah right
is uh there's this like continuum you
have to go on and then eventually you
get back to uh
hey this bitcoin thing is probably going
to be pretty valuable in the future
exactly yeah what what um what else are
you excited about in terms of just the
build out of infrastructure
right so you guys have done a ton
obviously in getting the three iq the
bitcoin fund
uh approved and kind of on to uh under
the exchange
what else do you see as important
milestones here to help a lot of these
investments
uh our investors and asset allocators
come in to uh come in
yeah i mean we're gonna be really early
so
if you think of a couple things you know
let's just talk about like
what would free iq have on a product
line invasive
everything that's going on with defy is
amazing right like block fight
you know i think you know morgan creek
might be in there but
you know zach prince and what they built
there is
is beautiful it's a whole new lending
management infrastructure
you know there's no reason i can't start
creating
literally money market funds paying
eight percent canadian dollars using my
you know stable coins and or my bitcoins
and hedging the positions out
so how well accepted would a
you know as far as we're concerned a you
know a
d5 digital asset um money market fund
look
i think it'd be amazing and you know
you're gonna get income seven eight
percent of income well versus what
point six on a ten year like forget it
so
so um i think there's an awful lot of
opportunities in there and you know that
we're obviously
looking at those um i do think the
uh you know when you start to see
uh the traditional banking methods
um and let's talk about central banks
for a second
the governor central bank of canada
could not create a stable coin yes they
could they already have it you know
you know they can program one but
if all canadians are going to hold their
money at the central bank of canada
what do we do with the most amazing
banking sector in the world you know
we've got
seven to ten banks mostly five and
that are very powerful it's not broken
well capitalized canadians don't have
any banking issues or banking problems
so why would the central bank of canada
want to f that up right well
they wouldn't so basically what will
happen is
essential currency is going to be held
by deposits because it'll be back one to
one
so all the canadian banks will start
competing for the deposits of my stable
coin
and they won't let that happen very long
they'll just take it out and say okay
qcad is now owned by all the canadian
banks and you know in
my version vision but then every
credit card loyalty program and in
canada we've got canadian tire hudson
bay company
tim hortons these are brand names like
you know it would be like your starbucks
or your
you know krogers or any of these kind of
people so
so any of those programs start companies
start adapting
uh stable coins i think that's when you
see the entire infrastructure going
and that's when bitcoin really
skyrockets
i tend to think that uh what zac has
built is just the start
for uh for block five but also we're
gonna see many many more entrepreneurs
follow in terms of building out this uh
what really ends up being just a mirror
image of the legacy financial world in
terms of providing all the financial
infrastructure that allows bitcoin to
thrive right
and if you kind of think about over the
last 11 years bitcoin has grown from
you know essentially on nobody's radar
you know you know
basically worth zero or three tenths of
a penny
uh to today being worth kind of ten
eleven thousand dollars
uh and now kind of the talk of finance
that's all
without a lot of infrastructure along
the way right yes you had the coin bases
and exchanges and things like that but
all the things that you're used to in
the financial services industry really
haven't been around and
they're coming online now but fast
forward 10 more years should i always
joke with people you think more people
are going to hold bitcoin or less
right in 10 years from now you think
it's gonna be easier to use or less
useful right and so
tends to be uh you know pretty much a
no-brainer in my opinion as to uh kind
of
the world that we're uh we're headed
towards but uh not everyone sees it that
way
well we'll take a piece from the the
disney fund and create the bitcoin
children's education fund how's that
sound so everybody can start saving for
their kids education in bitcoin
see how see where they're in 20 years
you know i have no idea how you finance
your kids to go to university in the
united states
and it's crazy university of toronto
it's crazy it is literally insane right
and the
the secret is that most of them aren't
doing it they're kids are just taking on
you know 200 000 100 000 worth of debt
to uh to go to college
it's going to be a pretty bad um
you know foot to start on if you will
right given the
the problems so we hope to help solve a
lot of those problems and
again pop a lot comes from you know for
us it's not bitcoin or gold an
investment advisor should own both
um it's not it's not radical it's not
this you know
when we filed our ethereum fund i i
can't say
that we have certain opinions that
they're not novel investments anymore
they're 12 years old
and yes it did take while we were doing
all of this gemini was working with us
step by step
to get their sakwan salk 2 type 1 type 2
audit things they were getting their
regulatory licenses none of this
happened fast and none of it was there
two years ago or a year and a half ago
right and that's why you know
grayscale's on a non-regulated uh
exchange we think a regulated exchange
has advantages so now pension funds
they can't overweight their otc holdings
or now you know family offices that say
we need certain
you know regulatory prospectuses around
investments that we'll invest in we
think we've now broken that
and the way i look at it is yes the osce
rejected us
in the new group that came in they
challenged us to take it to the highest
possible
level to get the proper approval
so we can easily say there's 10 000
pages of testimony
approved by a regulator approved by a
regulator
who did four years of due diligence
and rang us run us through the biggest
ringer
to make sure due diligence was properly
done
so we easily believe qbtc.u
is the cleanest most powerful product in
you know in the market today
i love it before we get into the rapid
fire questions
uh what is the place where people can
find you on the internet
or find out more about the bitcoin fund
yeah
www.3iq.ca.com.ca
and that's for canada the great white
north and
on there you'll have everything how many
bitcoin per unit
you know what's our our challenges is
we're trading at a 19
premium and our competitors are trading
at a nine percent premium today and i'm
going
i need to get my premium down i need
people to sell my bitcoin fund not buy
it they're all
buying it i need them to sell it to get
it down so
we hope to manage the premium a little
better when we have at the market our
etf comes out
in the next couple of weeks but yeah
visit us there
and as i said for canadians again you
get to put in retirement accounts and
then
tax free savings account something that
we have here and
you know it can change your life if
you're 23 years old you complace the 10
000
investment but if it goes up 10x or 100x
you've missed out on an amazing
opportunity so
i love that i asked the same two
questions everybody to wrap up
and then you're going to get to ask me
one first is what's the most important
book you've ever read
um
the most not the most important book i
i i've ever read but
recently the one that i read that was
the most fun was literally bitcoin
billionaires and the way he
writes and his tv show and everything he
does
is amazing i was absolutely you know
fascinated by it and and i like a good
feel-good story you know other than that
uh
i read for escapism but i'm also a big
sailor so
most of the important things i read are
about weather patterns and
weight patterns and you know what do you
do when your hurricane's coming and
you're sitting in the middle of the
ocean
yourself these are so i'll read
educational uh stuff mostly
um and then anything industry oriented
so
but um and i'd be remiss to say if i
didn't mention jack tater and chris
berniski's
but we're getting a little dated we need
we need version two jack if you're
listening
those are uh great suggestions uh second
question is more fun
aliens believer or non-believer oh i'm
gonna have to quote
and sing you know the late david bowie
there's a star man waiting in the sky
he'd like to come and see you but he
thinks he'll blow your mind
there so there's a star man waiting but
he'll blow our mind absolutely
that one of the best writers and one of
the greatest songs ever written
that is a fantastic way to answer that
question no one has ever said that
you could ask me one question to finish
up what you got for me fred well
how big are you gonna make your why did
you get into venture capital and
how big are you gonna make your venture
capital and how exciting is it i wanna
really know how you've gone because
that's obviously
you know you're half my age but you know
at some point in time that's what i'd
like to do tell me about
what why you did that because i'm really
fascinated
yeah i think um yeah i've been doing it
now for four years or so
and there was no grand plan but if you
kind of look with hindsight bias
there's definitely this belief that
companies have been staying
private longer most of the gains have
been occurring in the private market
there are still great opportunities in
the public market it's just that you
know kind of
the public market companies all the
private market value was already sucked
out of them right by the the private
market investors
and so uh that game ends up having
a attractiveness to a specific type of
investor
if you'd like to be the less kind of
what are the
you know financials and what's the cash
burn and the opex and kind of
actually looking at financial statements
uh you're probably more of a public
market type investor
but in the earliest stages of uh
building these companies
uh there really isn't any of that right
and so what you're doing
is uh you're basically optimistically
believing at a person
uh and in a vision they have for
something that they want to create
uh but that's why there's such great
returns available to investors
is uh these entrepreneurs are literally
dedicating years of their life
uh to not only recruit other smart
intelligent hard-working ambitious
people
uh to work on hard problems but also of
their own you know personal sacrifices
with themselves their families etc
to build these businesses and literally
they are creating this stuff out of thin
air
um and kind of building value and the
hope is that those companies will
capture that value
and so i just really enjoy that right i
mean there's now
i've been doing it long enough to have
multiple founders who pitched me
uh an idea uh and a problem that they
were going to go solve
uh to the point where they've grown big
enough to see
doing hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue right and it's just really cool
to see
you know somebody who set out to uh to
do something uh and kind of through all
the obstacles all the challenges
uh get there and and uh so for me it's
you know
yeah sure we can make some money uh
doing this but at the same time
uh it's much more just about watching
these founders
uh kind of build this stuff and and uh i
personally just get enjoyment out of
this whole idea of
you know betting on somebody early on
their journey to go do something and if
they're successful
it's a pretty cool ride to be along for
yeah moving from
a user of capital to a provider of
capital it's got to be the day that you
put a big smile on your face and
congratulations on everything you've
accomplished i'm a big fan
as you know absolutely friend well
listen i'm a big fan of what you guys
are doing as well and i i think that uh
you guys are just getting started so we
will uh
we will have to do this again my friend
uh at some point when
you guys have more news but uh just keep
going because i knew that what uh what
you guys have done so far is not easy
and kind of where the ambitions lie uh
are even harder
so uh just uh just keep going for all of
us
great thanks great seeing you